okay great so welcome everyone for I
guess our first zoom quantum seminar of
the program but we'll have these every
Tuesdays as we discussed earlier at the
time might move to 10 a.m. PST to
accommodate people in Europe so today
we're happy to have Chris Schaffner you
know aunt Scylla hung and he's going to
tell us oh and so I can see that Chris
used to put the slides from Afghan so
this is to tell us about work with if
Gabe would like who's also in the
program Alex Quinn within the program
Stacey Jeffery Christian missions and
and so he's going to tell us about
secure multi-party quantum computation
okay all right and feel free to
questions yes thank you very much
tomorrow so and I cannot see your faces
but I think you can see mine so I'll try
to smile from time to time so as you
just said this is joint work with a lot
of people and also that's the second
slide you see like I haven't changed
much and I would already in the first
like thank if game for making basically
all the slides I only changed the
epsilon fraction of them so thanks a lot
okay so we're going to talk about
multi-party computation and for this
hour so multi-party computation is when
a bunch of people come together and they
want to compute something together so in
this example everybody has an input
sorry some some numbers and they want to
figure out for instance who has the
biggest number you think of salaries
thing goes like fortunes now in the
millionaires problem people want to
figure out who has most money and so
that's their input and if we had a
trusted third party in the middle but
that everybody trusts the players could
simply just send all the inputs to that
party the party would compute his
function and output output so in this
case and it would could figure out what
is the largest number 302 could announce
that to the players or maybe even better
she could kind of compute in
visual functions for the players and
just sent back for instance yes you are
the one with the highest input
oh no you are not that would even
further minimize the amount of
information they play yet slow
so that's what we want to achieve an
example and this is the ideal situation
we want to achieve in a multi-party
computation but of course in
cryptography we are concerned with the
setting where we don't have this trusted
third party so what we can do instead is
we can create come up with protocols
that try to emulate this situation and
there are questions where we still see
the title slide here oh really
is this the case with everybody yes okay
that's not good
let me see if I can fix it
you
good thank you Tom
for I went through all the whole talk
let me try to share this again
yes oh it looks it's moving now oh but
it's that sharing it's paused try to
move it so we can see if it moves
bring it bring your shared window to the
front what does it mean so it's not
moving now it moved like once and maybe
I should let me remove maybe you can
first go to presentation wood and then
share maybe it could be a separate
windows in which it shows the I have now
unplugged I have a second screen and
what it still says sharing its post
strange did you do what norbert
suggested which is first order
presentation and then click on share
screen in fact and I wouldn't know then
there is no thing to share the screen if
it's a full screen so right now I guess
you see neither coast screen now it says
sharing is past
okay but anyone has experience with this
I don't know I mean I I would switch now
to to zoom which I don't know it works
on Macs or whatever but and then try to
share from there because now this window
should be open which the presentation
events can you do like on Emma on the
windows you talk to switch to zoom yeah
it doesn't it doesn't do it it doesn't
[Music]
look stupid presentations when in kind
of separate windows the fullscreen part
so if the sharing shares a specific
window so you see your flowers now yeah
okay that's a good sign whoa how do you
well so I'm sharing my desktop instead
of the the my only day question is is
this black is this gray box back okay
okay so it seems to be working very good
okay sorry everyone
so okay the trick is to share your
desktop and not the actual the keynote
application right so if can thanks a lot
for your slides here are the flowers
because you haven't seen that before
multi-party computation I just explained
so here is the example with actual
numbers
everybody has every player's an input X
I and if he had this trusted third party
let's call her Shafi for instance
somebody we all trust she could actually
choose compute this function and send
back the answer she could even compute
individual functions for every player as
inputs of all the the auspice function
of all the inputs and inform the players
about the outcomes and that's what we
ideally money I'm gonna emulate with a
protocol so a protocol here is sketched
just a form of interaction between
players in fact and not all the arrows
are drawn here in fact all the players
can talk to each other in a protocol and
we still want to do the same thing so
what we want is we wanna achieve so
called input privacy and that's that
means that basically the inputs of the
player should be hidden beyond what they
will learn anyway from the outcome of of
the function and this should hold even
in the case if we have adversarial
players and so even if some players are
misbehaving means not following the
protocol it should still be guaranteed
that these players even together cannot
learn the inputs of honest players
that's one thing we want that the other
thing is what we want to achieve is
correctness
so that means well if everybody is
honest and everybody should receive that
right output but it should even be the
case that if we have adversarial players
like on this picture then it should
still be guaranteed that the honest
players are receiving and correct output
so the the function evaluated on actual
inputs but of course there's a few
things we cannot prevent in this case
namely that these honest players could
simply lie about their inputs I mean
it's not even fully defined what it
means for them to have an input nor they
could just behave in some arbitrary way
dishonest way but nevertheless no matter
how they behave there should be some
input that that's kind of assumed for
them so that's that's how they
participate in the protocol and the
evaluation of the pérignon correctness
still requires that the correct function
is computed and given to the onus
players even if they lie about their
their own or if they provide different
kind of inputs they're dishonest players
and there's another problem if you
assume that we have more dishonest
players like this case a four out of the
six players are dishonest then there's
an issue that they can basically simply
just walk away once they have seen
enough so there's something that we
cannot avoid and this can actually be
formally proven that and dishonest
players can simply abort the protocol
and this can be kind of unfavorable
unfair for honest players because it
might be that they already have learned
their their outputs but if they don't
like the the outcome of the protocol
they were just bored and walk away so
that's something we cannot avoid and we
basically just have to live with that
sometimes these protocols will no simply
report so what we want to do in this
talk is the quantum version of all this
so
or to call quantum multi-party
computation or NP q c is a multi-party
quantum computation so there's always
the constant confusion of very exactly
we put the Q but I think we set out on
multi-party quantum computation and the
setting here is as follows so do you
actually see my mouse pointer yes okay
so so we assume that all the players
have some quantum status input so
principle they hold registers r1 up to
r6 in this case and they want to perform
some arbitrary quantum computation on
these inputs so in this protocol in this
talk I'm gonna present a protocol for
doing that and here is your kind of the
parameters we're gonna achieve so if you
call K the number of the total number of
players then actually we'll be able to
tolerate up to came on as minus 1
adversarial players so it can be like an
extreme case there's really just one
honest player and this whole protocol
and kind of all the rest are playing
together against that person and
nevertheless you want to have some
security guarantees in that case and
then what we do is we settle for
computational security but I can already
tell you now that in fact everything we
do is kind of an information theoretic
upgrade from whatever whatever comes
from the classical multi-party
computation that we using under the hood
so all the computational assumptions in
this talk are basically hidden in the
classical multi-party computation part
furthermore what you're gonna do is
we're gonna kind of get to this protocol
build this protocol basically gauge by
gate so basically I'll show you how to
do particular types of gates and in the
end we're gonna end up with a protocol
that takes a certain amount of rounds so
the round is basically K times D / ki
okay as I said it's the number total
number of players and D is the the form
of depth of the quantum computation
gonna perform and in particular it's the
C naught and
the depth of the quantum computation so
for those who don't know what what that
means exactly you can just think of like
the total number of gates that is
performed but basically it's kind of if
you if you layer them and then the D is
the scene of the key depth of this
computation perform and we're gonna make
heavy use of classical multi-party
computation so we are simply assume that
we have a trusted third party and Shafie
that she's gonna help us with with all
of the classical computations we have to
prove so that's the goal normally now I
would look at the audience and see if I
see any question marks in the faces but
I can't so please let me know if there's
any question so far just nobody is
saying or raising its hand and I assume
everything is good so I will quickly
sketch what
[Music]
previous approaches have done to achieve
multi-party quantum computation so the
first one is using secret sharing so
this is similar to the kind of classic
MPC protocol like the bgw style protocol
where and basically players share their
inputs so how does it work so this has
been suggested by capo Gottesman smith
min or CDM Smith and beta came later
with an upgrade and but the basic idea
is that you take inputs a and player one
holds a quantum states this blue dot and
what its gonna do is is gonna split this
quantum up state up in shares so
basically two secret sharing of this
quantum state and you distribute that to
the players so it's the kind of the
classic distribute and compute paradigm
that is often also followed in classical
multi-party computation and so you might
have dishonest players so but they even
if they kind of don't follow what
they're supposed to do with their shares
longest you have enough other players
than kind of the information about
player ones input is still there so you
can you can work with that however you
also see the problem already here and
say assuming you have three dishonest
players out of the six in total well
then you you will have a problem because
in fact now if you have more than half
of the player or half or more of the
players corrupted well then it's
actually in a quantum setting not
possible anymore that both the sets now
honest players and dishonest players
hold the whole information about the
console state because obviously that
would contradict a no-cloning theorem we
were able to extract the whole state out
of the three shares of the dishonest
players and the three shares of the
honest players then you could actually
throw in the state so and one gets into
trouble with this approach if basically
and more than half half or more of the
players are are dishonest
works for a strict majority of owners
players then the other approach that has
been suggested so far for the setting of
multi-party quantum computation is the
so called DNS approach after degree
Nielsen and salvia and they basically
looked at the two-party case and they
use a different kind of technique namely
they use quantum authentication codes to
protect the inputs so they basically
assume that or they show how to encode
players input so that once this put this
input is kind of sent to other players
in particular to dishonest players it's
protected so even if they try to do
something to this input then they will
they may gonna have a hard time so
because of the authentication code and
the hope is of course because so they
can do two party computation or they can
tolerate and one dishonest player so
which is already half of the players so
the hope is basically if one generalizes
this approach then maybe it's possible
to to tolerate up to K minus 1 these
honest players so that's basically the
approach here we are taking here but we
will we will do some additional upgrades
to this scheme that is that was proposed
by DNS and in order to explain all this
I will start off with telling you a
little bit about how to authenticate
quantum states and basically if you're
watching this on video you should pause
your video now and click on that link
and go back and watch if gates tutorial
from the bootcamp about this because all
that I'm gonna say on this slide is
actually just a recap of what she's been
explaining in more details there so what
we're going to use is the so-called
clifford code and so the key is an
element from the clifford group over n
plus 1 qubits so this is a subgroup for
all of all possible unitary you can
perform on n plus 1 qubits the the
clifford group is generated by the
not transformed square root of Z cenotes
and the good thing is that it looks it
looks random so basically applying a
random Clifford operation basically
randomized as you yours your state and
in a sense also encrypts your state so
here's how the encoding works
we take your so this is a single qubit
if you want to encode this into the
clifford code what you do is you simply
attach some so-called traps so just zero
qubits in a zero state end of them and
you apply the CD key which is just a
Clifford operation on these and Poisson
qubits and in order to decode you simply
apply the inverse of C so C dagger and
then you measure the traps so you check
whether the traps are still in the all
zero state and one can then show a
theorem can make as kind of security
claims for this kind of code and
informally one can prove that if an
attacker comes so for any a an attack n
plus one qubits the probability that a
change is the data qubits sigh but it's
not detected at decoding so not setting
off any traps this is actually very
small so that's the reason why why this
is a good way to to encode qubits and if
you want to know well what I said before
the Clifford code also provides privacy
this is not a coincidence because
actually in the quantum case one can
show that you have an authentication
code then actually it necessarily also
has to encrypt and if you want to know
more about this then you should really
go back and watch this tutorial so far
so good maybe somebody can say yes or
click on yes because I'm feeling kind of
alone here
yes great great
let me see ok there are 23 people
listening
so next let's use this Clifford code in
the in the multi-party quantum
communication protocol quantum
computation protocol so let's say people
encode their inputs into the into the
Clifford code and tell you a little bit
more how to actually do this and well
immediately you see there's some trouble
with that well how can we be sure that
dishonest players actually do this
properly no they are they are trying to
disrupt this whole thing so how can we
make sure that they actually properly
encodes their input into the clicker
code
another issue is I mean once you have
authenticated quantum states I mean they
are protected from being altered so on
the other hand we want to compute on
them so like how can you actually do
this so this seems to be like
contradicting and the answers to like
both of these questions is well we're
gonna ask Shafi to help us so we are
going to use classical multi-party
computation to to to to solve these
problems so
first idea is basically so like how
could we encode these quantum states in
a clay fur coat so if you kind of do a
straightforward generalization from from
DNS so what they do is well let's say
let's say the first qubit of everyone
gets encoded into the cliff record as a
as an outline now send this to the
second player now the second second prey
is just gonna put another encoding on
top in a sense of like what I described
here just add another and trap qubits in
a zero state and apply a big clifford
like a bigger Clifford operation on top
of this so notice now that we not only
have n plus one but we actually have two
n plus one qubits in total so this will
have the following effect for for our
two these second trap qubits are kind of
accessible because I mean you just
applied C to itself on the other hand he
doesn't know what C 1 is and so these
first players trap cupid's we kind of
are inaccessible for him so it will be
difficult for him to check whether the
first players actually properly put zero
traps here so here's the first place
where we can ask our classical
multi-party computation for help because
we will assume that the classical NPC
knows C 1 C 2 basically all these
operations there that are applied so
what we could do is we could ask the the
NPC to kind of provide us with a
description of this operation which
would undo C 2 so let's say we take this
state here and apply it to to the state
we have this was undo C 2 it would undo
C 1 and then we can basically choose
which of the trap could qubits we want
to reveal so for instance we could kind
of reveal now player one straight qubit
and could then test those so with the
help of the NPC we could kind of change
the state into something where we can
and make these new trips accessible and
you could imagine that you can continue
this and so if you do this and all round
in this state goes around then it will
the
it will just grown every time and trap
qubits are added and a new big Clifford
is put on top so I think this would work
of course one would have to prove that
it actually does but the obvious
drawback of this is that the cipher text
so they encoded cubed Q quantum states
they just increase the number of players
so basically just to encode one players
input you will end up with n times K and
it's a security parameter in case the
number of players plus the qubit that
you wanted to encode so so that's not
what we're doing
but instead and we invented basically a
so-called public authentication test to
get around this problem so how does this
work
well let's take this first players input
so what we gonna do is we gonna send
this around but now so maybe so instead
of adding n trap qubits in the zero
state what we're gonna do is we're gonna
add 2n + 0 state trap qubits and then it
simply just sent at that state around
and have all the players apply a bleep
cliff heart operation on it but is
Clifford is now from 2 n plus 1 qubits
so in this case the cipher text or
encoded qubit state does not grow it
just remains 2 n plus 1 and in order to
analyze this so we're gonna call this
big operation C and nobody knows that
because they've just applied their own
individual effort and the traps have
been inserted by the first player now
we're gonna ask Jaffe to help us because
and what she's gonna do is we're gonna
kind of do some randomized check on
these traps so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna select a random function so
this is this G is basically that you can
think of it as a binary matrix of size 2
and by 2n which is invertible
and if you have such a such a thing more
than this function it will actually only
output zero if and only if the input was
0 so it's kind of a zero test and the
high-level idea is to basically apply
this random function G on this trap part
it says size 2m and we gonna measure
half of them and the fact that it's
picked at random it kind of tests
randomly half of the position it
actually look thus almost the same as
testing all of all of these traps so
what we gonna do this was just a
high-level idea concretely the NPC is
gonna compute this operation here and
we're gonna ask player one to apply that
so so pick a random string R and pick
basically a random clifford of n plus 1
cubits C prime and then ask the player 1
to apply this operation so this is just
given to player 1 as one big Clifford
operation and you can easily see what
happens if if it's applied to the state
so before that so what is going to
happen is like you're gonna undo the C
you're gonna apply the G parts or this
randomized operation on the trap part we
don't do anything on the on the data
qubit and then you actually kind of put
a one-time pad so you randomly flip the
last and qubits and you kind of properly
encodes the first and +1 qubits
so the next step is to ask why you want
to measure the last qubits and check if
the outcome is 0 well that was before
applying a one-time pad or kind of the
randomization so now you should check
that the outcome is R so that's the
procedure and the result what we can
prove is that indeed if this checks out
then the player is going to end up with
a kind of properly authenticated quantum
state so then DC prime from here
is gonna be applied to the data qubit
and basically traps that we have now
verified that they are a zero so the
advantage of this public authentication
test is that only one player actually
performs the test applies exclaims what
he measures and all players can verify
the test through the classical IBC the
fact that the FPC knows what's going on
and knows this our that that that makes
this this test kind of public so this
test will be used at different stages of
our protocol for instance it can be used
to test and codings well that's what was
the original motivation no like that
people that player have properly encoded
their input but we will also see how to
use this test to kind of verify that the
computation step has been executed
obviously all right I'm going to go on
and describe kind of the computation
parts to you and maybe yes it may be
time to ask questions yeah so so it
seems like any player can cause that
authentication to fail by I mean if they
do anything
when you pass it around right if any
player does anything that's correct and
so you there's no way to identify it was
the problem no so so what we do there is
no kind of sometimes in classical and PC
I call it straighter tracing so kind of
have an idea like who acted wrong what I
would even like accuse each other and so
you know one of the two Lister is there
is the one it must be dishonest in our
case it's simply if if something goes
wrong we will upward and I think this
can be somehow justified by thinking of
like the extreme case never where
there's really only one honest player so
then any and
anybody else's is possibly dishonest I
other questions at the moment so I've
kind of given you an idea of what we
want to do I've talked a little bit
about talked a little bit about
authentication I presented you this
public authentication test I am now
going to describe you how to do the
computation steps so basically what we
want to do is we have this properly
encoded qubits input but also is good
this could this kind of can be states
that are intermediate states of the
computation so and what we want to do is
we want to apply gates to it and certain
types of gates and I can split it up in
four different cases but basically we
want to end up with again properly and
properly encoded States now maybe under
a different clifford C Prime but this
gate should be applied to the data cube
that's our goal and so there I'm going
to talk about four different classes of
gates they didn't want to apply the
first one is 1 cubed clifford's the
second is going to be C NOx and then
some non Clifford operation and finally
computational basis measurements so
let's start with the first one that one
is the is easy because if you want to
apply only single qubit clifford's so
let's focus on on one of the states here
it's properly encoded and what we're
gonna do is basically we're not gonna do
anything
quantum we're just gonna ask the
classical npc to kind of update the key
Nia so the classical Shafie she knows
all these seeds now these are the keys
of the encoding of all the players and
if you want to apply a single qubit
clifford gate is g2 it what we what we
gonna do is we gonna just simply ask
Shafie to change the key and that you
remembered from the original C to a C
prime or C prime is defined as this
original C well like the identity times
the gate we want the inverse of the gate
you want to apply and the original C
because if you do that then we can
easily verify that once we take out then
this this blue
stayed here I will decode to the to the
inverse of this new key and so if you
kind of plug it in well they will undo
that clifford and then will actually
apply the gate of you got so so we will
end up with the right with the right
state and we simply achieve that by like
not doing anything on the quantum level
but just basically updates the key and
that the npc remembers so that's kind of
an easy and easy trick to handle that
case so far so good
alright then the next case is C naught
and that's a bit more tricky because now
we have we have to handle two qubits and
they are both of time are properly
encoded and if you just try to the same
strategy as before kind of do the
inverse C naught and then and then the
encoding out by just updating the keys
well that will not work because this is
not kind of properly encoded anymore
it's not in this product form that we
meet in order to continue our
computation afterwards so on a high
level instead what we're going to do is
we're going to ask player 1 to perform a
computation and that's gonna be this
computation so it's basically undoing
the the clifford's of the encoding
remember a chef he knows this iconic so
she can cook up this operation she can
choose freshly random C 1 Prime and C 2
Prime and then kind of give just this
big operation to play a run to be to
perform so basically undo these flavors
then the do the proper C naught and then
put you and colleagues on top so and
then in order to kind of show that this
actually worked and player 1 will
execute the the public authentication
test this and I'm cheating quite a bit
here because in fact this is more this
is really just a high-level idea and in
fact the the real protocol is quite a
bit more complicated because on top of
this we have to just in order to perform
this first step we actually have to send
this whole state around so basically it
has to go from Player to Player and they
all kind of do their share in order to
perform this operation so this will
actually require a whole round of
quantum communication where both these
qubits actually go through the whole
players and again the reason is
basically because how can we trust
player 1 to actually do this if it's
dishonest so somehow and the state has
to pass by it
least one owners player for this to
actually happen and so we basically have
to send it along all the players all
right so that's the see not part I will
move on to the long as there's no
questions I will move on to the non
Clifford gate and in our case we choose
the t gate and it's kind of the the
square root of the the phase gate or the
fourth gate and we resolve to kind of
the standard trick in full tolerant
computing namely metric state
computation so I assume that we can
actually try to do a little poll so who
has not seen this magic state
computation before so now if I go to
participants I can see who is still
awake and you can press on yes and no so
the question is who has not seen magic
state computation or double negation we
not raised his hand okay you notice not
seen you before
good there are few people saying or not
but just judging from the name I
basically know that most of you have
seen this before and also see blinking
there's a chit haven't seen when she
says before okay quick and so magic
states are magic
but really they are not it's not that's
spectacular what people call magic
states in a quantum case is this you
basically take the plus state plus is
actually 0 plus 1 like the even
superposition between 0 and 1 and if you
apply a TK to it the ticket is just this
thing up here then that's what we call a
magic state and remember the goal is
that we have some qubits sy and we more
basically want to apply the T operation
to it and this little circuit what we
call magic state computation does the
job so turns out that if you put in
magic States
here on the second wire and you put in
your Cupid in the first wire and you
apply these operations you do a see not
you measure this and classically
controlled on the outcome zero one you
either you apply an X and a P just some
other quantum gates then it turns out
that you have applied the T operation so
this is something you can verify on
paper and that means basically that once
we have magic States we will be able to
apply T gates using this procedure
however remember we want to do
everything in coded way in our case so
we'll have encoded States sy and we also
need encoded magic States and those
together using this procedure will and
we will end up with kind of encoded
states where the T cake has been applied
to our data cube so Chris this is the
this is a way to compute the ticket
given so a pre process the gate in some
sense um yes
yeah together with the ability to do si
not ex choose X R and big gate that's it
yes exactly the kind of the magic is why
this is called magic is that indeed this
this the circuit here are just Clifford
operations from a lower class and having
this additional magic state is resources
which do not depend on the states that
you actually want to apply the TK to and
you are able to perform a ticket so is
this specific to the ticket or can I do
you know a larger class of computations
this way yes you can this kind of this
specific circuit I'm showing here I mean
these operations here depend on what you
want to form and also of course what you
put in here but there are equivalent
ways of doing this also for different
kind of resource states but the point is
basically I think any gate outsides the
the Clifford group will kind of
give you a universal set of so so
there's two questions how do we get this
encoded magic states and how do we
perform this circuit and so the problem
here in this multi-party computation
setting is that nobody can be trusted to
actually create properly encoded magic
States so what we're gonna do is
procedure magic state generation so you
basically just gonna ask one player's I
player one to generate a lot of this
encoded magic States and then we're
going to use some cut and choose
technique to make sure that they're
these states are actually good enough so
we just ask player 1 to generate a lot
of them and then we send around this
whole bunch to basically the player then
every player will test n random States
of that and whenever I say random of
course I mean Shafi is gonna instruct
them and which of the states they should
actually test so whenever we need
classical randomness we're gonna get
that from the classical IPC then this
just goes around everybody takes n of
them and tests and again we abort if
something is not good if the tests don't
past and we abort we sent them all
around hopefully we went we will end up
with enough of them at the end so that's
how we've chosen the remaining we want
to make sure that the remaining n copies
are pretty good they're pretty good I
mean that this very high probability
only a small small constant fraction of
them is not the right state and but with
what you want to do is actually want to
have one state which is kind of
exponentially close to the right state
but for that there's a there's a
procedure called magic States
destination and this is yet another kind
of part of the magic namely that's only
a Clifford circuit so again we've kind
of only operations from our lower class
which we already know how to perform we
can do that
on end states in order to distill one
state which now has the guarantee that
it's exponentially close to the correct
state to a correct magic state so this
remaining copy will be very good again
of course in the Clifford circuit there
might be randomness and that's again
what we get out of the the classical
obesity
I'm so sorry can you can you say again
what the distillation process does it
takes n states of which some are
guaranteed to be good and yes after this
cut and choose procedure we are we have
the guarantee that only a small constant
fraction of that of these states that
remain in the middle are not good are
not the right states but what we want
this we actually want one state of which
we know that which we have to guarantee
that is exponentially good to the to
this encoded magic state I think it's
just a quantum distillation procedure
again well-known for people who do fault
tolerance because that's essential thing
in quantum computing in quantum
computing and fortunately this is kind
of it's easy to do it's it's in this
lower class it's a clifford circuit that
does this and it comes with the
guarantee that the remaining state then
is actually very good in the sense of
like exponentially close to the right
state so that's great
so quick summary so far Meah
we have protocols that can perform one
qubit Clifford's this we've seen it's
just like updating the key that was that
is remembered by the NPC you've seen how
to do see knots so that's basically
asking a player to up apply an operation
and then send it around and actually
perform this public authentication test
then we have just seen how to do t gates
namely we do magic state computation and
we generate encoded magic States however
in order to actually perform this
circuit even in an encoded form on
encoded States what we need to do is we
need to do this measurement as well so
the last thing kind of the last missing
ingredient and I have to show you is how
to do computational basis measurements
because you need that in order to
perform and this is this magic state
computation so here is how this goes and
so this is the last step of the
computation part so let's say we have an
encoded qubit and just rewrite it in the
computational basis so M it's just a
single bit this is these are the
amplitudes of this bit these are fully
proper traps and then a clifford apply
it on the whole thing now what we're
going to do in order to kind of measure
this data qubit in a computation map and
a base basis is that the npc samples a
bunch of classical strings are in s and
post one bit strings and c and then
again Shafi instructs this player to
apply a big operation namely this year
I'm gonna parse that in a second so so
basically it undoes the clifford well so
let's get rid of the clifford then we do
a bunch of C naught operations that
whether we do them or not are dictated
by this random string C and basically
just C not this kind of data cubed into
the traps and notice if if M is 0 then
this is not doing anything and if M is 1
then we basically spreading these ones
to some of the traps in in here so
that's what they see C does so the C not
operation is and on top of this we
basically just apply one-time pad so
this this is just a one-time pad
encryption so random face and random
Eclipse and all this this whole package
again is just given as one big operation
to the player as an instruction to apply
and finally the player measures in the
computational basis and the outcome will
be R prime so this is just a string that
comes out and now the NPC can can do a
check whether this has been properly
performed namely its gonna check whether
this R prime that comes out is the one
time pad key so this
just this bit flips here it is X so this
is this are and exhort with the beats
that has been measured so whether there
exists beat side of zero one and and
then you either have zero zero in case M
is zero or you have a one here if the
ultimen was one and basically see this
part so because we have been spreading
the ones to the traps so that's the
check that the NPC is going to do of
course now we have to prove that this
actually works but somehow intuitively
this is doing the right thing so this
how you this is how you perform a
computation of basis measurement state
and now the npc at least knows the
measurement outcome that was the end so
now it depends either the the NPC can
announce that to the players or announce
that to the next player that has to
perform the computation remember we want
to for instance we need that in the in
the magic state computation so here
these conditionals the these outcomes
are now known to the NPC and so the NPC
can then tell the player whether they
have to apply this X but that's how we
can actually perform the circuit all
right I'm close to the end I see like 45
minutes 15 minutes so time for summary
we have constructed a protocol for
multi-party computation of any quantum
circuits here's about properties so we
are computationally secure but as I said
at the very beginning basically we are
information theoretically secure modulo
how secured the the classical NPC is so
that one requires computational
assumptions but we can actually even tie
in into this pre-processing paradigm so
often classically secure multi-party
computation protocols against dishonest
majorities are of the form that you do
some pre-processing phase where you need
computational assumptions and in order
to generate some correlated randomness
may be multiple indicated multiplication
triple
for those no and and then you can
perform information theoretically secure
efficient computation aid once the
inputs are known and we basically tie
into that step so so if you can do this
first pre-processing step in the
classical world and from then on you
actually have an information theoretic
security even in the quantum gates and
we can tolerate up up to K minus one
cheaters if you have K players in total
then in terms of efficiency so our
states basically our encodings are most
of size 2n plus 1 versus if you do the
straightforward generalization from DNS
you would get K and plus 1 and the
tickets operations we do in order to
generate these magic States and in our
case we need like K times and magic
States to start with whereas if you do
the naive extension of DNS then you
would end up with something
exponentially the number of times but to
be I mean they have not analyzed this
setting for the multiplayer case then
yeah then you have to do a bit of
accounting to kind of figure out what
the number of communication rounds is
but it's basically K times D now okay
it's D plus log of the security
parameter where D is kind of counting
the the layers of difficult operations
and in our case difficult means either C
not 14 because for both of those we need
kind of to go around the number of
players months and there's a bunch of
things you can do in parallel so you
have to kind of sit down to count a
little bit like what what exactly are
the things that can be parallelized but
then you will end up with is this number
of course of communication routes
all right maybe a bunch of open
questions that's my last slide
so the question maybe for V not
another's I think you know if actually
already quickly talked about this and do
are their post quantum secure classical
multi-party computations protocols that
are good for dishonest majority I think
as far as I remember from me note he
said yeah sure they exist depends on how
efficient you want to be yes I think so
when I looked into the into the later
literature there are kind of the most
efficient protocols that are actually
used in practice use these ot extensions
and they're I think as far as I know
only proven in the random Oracle model I
don't know if there's also Q ROM proofs
for that but that's I think one of the
things that one would have to check then
yeah so there's a bunch of kind of
technical questions about our protocol
can you do the C not operation I said
for now it requires one round of quantum
communication so we need to a scientist
state around but it's not fully clear
whether it is actually needed so it
might be possible to do this without so
maybe actually have these authentication
checks only at the at the beginning at
the end so that would save some
additional rounds of quantum
communication it's just we don't see an
attack it's more like our proof
techniques at the moment they don't
allow for hope for that then the
question is can you can you get more
efficient protocols for more specific
functionalities now this works for any
quantum polynomial time computation but
maybe if you if you were zoom into like
more specific class of circuits then it
might be possible to gain if its
efficiency here there and I think an
interesting question could be like the
comparison with classical MPC which
turns out to very to be a very versatile
tool so not just to
MPC for the sake of MPC but also use it
as an ingredient to build other things
like your knowledge probes or digital
signatures and at least to us it wasn't
like straightforward how this would
actually work and whether these such use
cases can be translated and to the case
of multi-party quantum computation and
but that's maybe just a lack of
knowledge of literature maybe maybe some
people more familiar or totally familiar
with classical and the signal can chime
in here and let us know maybe there's
there might be applications of doing
this also the marketplace alright and
thank you very much for your attention
also to the to the sponsors of this work
and I'm happy to take questions now
you
you
so crystal the the number of rounds is
you know even if you had the best
possible classical MPC protocol let's
say a two rounds applause okay yes
virtual applause okay so yeah even if
you had the best MPC protocol
classically you will still need a lot of
rounds here right yes you're sorry
like one for every ticket kind of yeah
okay at least for the way we do it yeah
I mean we really make have use basically
it's partly it's because of simplicity
and we can just like delegate any
classical communication computation to
the NPC which makes it easier to control
more because just assuming a trusted
third party but but yeah I might it
might be possible to kind of reduce the
calls to the NPC me quite quite
significantly we have already tried to
optimize thanks
this is a bit of a sight question maybe
but these protocols they never have like
I think it's related to Dan's question
from like abort resistance in any way
like if any just even one party decides
to be unhappy and some of the texts are
supposed to do then you just quit yes
yes
so the that's what we do basically from
the point of view that yeah if you
cannot get around abort in the case
where you have a dishonest majority but
of course I think in an NPC world and
maybe be not concerned more about this
there are ways they're kind of more I
mean there's like a million different
models anyway but there are kind of more
realistic adversary models where you
have first of all you can look at
adaptive adversaries that kind of only
corrupt players during the protocol and
then you can also have mixed versions of
like you only allow to corrupt so many
and so many and then you get you you
might get different results about the
board so you can kind of have some
partial fairness but even if you had
that for the classical NPC you'd still
have to change your protocol a little
bit like this yeah I guess so yeah yeah
I would suspect I don't know I mean you
know it's do you know whether there's
kind of kind of water what our natural
relaxations of having this abort around
it's a little bunch maybe the other
crypto people here would know more but
there's security with the bought this
fairness which is which is a strong
condition you cannot deceive it bit more
than after play as being dishonest yeah
and and I guess with honest majority you
can get everything you can get you you
can get the best possible yeah well yeah
there are bunch of relaxations I'm not
sure exactly
to look at them more details better they
whether these kind of improvements to
the classical NPC are compatible with
our extension of the quality case I
think that's it's not touching Eric
you
yes are there any other quick
you
you